now since we've been stuck at home my
pal Andy Ritcher and I decided to have a
little pizza making contest yes we did
we figured it'd be a good way to kill
some time and have something to eat
yeah and here's the interesting thing
neither one of us has ever made a pizza
before isn't that right Andy I know can
you believe it I just never never tried
to make a pizza before you think you
have a good pizza I think you might be
the winner here yeah I think I think
mine is pretty good I think it's gonna
be tough to beat all right I admire your
confidence let's see Andy's pizza you go
first Andy all right here we go here it
is oh my god
that's horrifying it's pretty good for a
first try yeah oh yeah let's see your
pizza then smarty pants all right I got
my pizza right here and there it is look
at that beautiful pizza right there
obviously ordered I didn't order this
pizza
I made this pizza hmm fantastic Rach
ordered it you got on the phone and you
ordered it no way I'm gonna order pizza
right now it's too risky look you know
damn well Little Caesars is offering no
contact delivery they made that pizza
and a 475 degree oven
it was never touched by human hands
again and Little Caesars is offering
free delivery this week and you know
that it's all done on the Little Caesars
app Andy there's no way I knew about the
Little Caesars app no way then why is
there a little Caesars box behind you
they're family momento Andy I gotta go
and you're breaking up you're breaking
up
bat-signal free delivery offer for
online orders of $10 more small order
fee for orders less than $10 taxes still
apply delivery available from
participating locations offer valid from
March 30th to April 12 2020